so do we have a name no okay we have we
have some um really strong options well
after airing out a couple options Kylie
Jenner reveals the name of her and
Travis Scott's son I'm waiting for him
to just name himself as the little one
prepares to celebrate his first birthday
I'm obsessed with it the beauty Mogul
and Travis Scott's second child's name
is spelled a-i-r-e and the announcement
kicked off speculation is that said like
air or Airy well Kylie didn't let the
debate drag on for too long she chimed
in while responding to a comment about
the question and the verdict is air I
would love my true fans to know all my
personal stuff of course the
long-awaited news comes as Mom and Dad
take a breather a source tells E.T the
pair is on a break adding quote the two
have had an up and down relationship and
although they aren't together right now
it doesn't mean it's over for good
our source says they live different
Lifestyles and that's been a big issue
quote with two kids Kylie doesn't go out
too much Travis on the other hand lives
a life of late nights in the studio and
going out with friends but that being
said Kylie's gotta step out for Paris
Fashion Week
[Music]
on Monday she roared into the City of
Lights with a lion's head bust on her
shoulder captioning her faux fur look
Beauty and the Beast and she was even
spotted vibing to Irina Shake who was
sporting the same ensemble
[Music]
and speaking of the Wild Kingdom Air's
name is a complete 180 from his original
moniker wolf
was never on our list okay
um it just was actually something Chloe
suggested and I like to do this I like
the name I don't think anything I still
like I love it I love it I like wolf I
just wasn't him the proud mom dropped
these snaps on Instagram over the
weekend and Kylie's inner circle's
obsessed with his social media debut I
mean he he definitely gives off Boy
energy Sister Chloe proclaims the king
young king while Haley Bieber wrote air
Angel and Kylie opened up to her BFF
last year I think that things get over
analyzed and their interview might add a
little context to why Kylie left fans in
suspense what is your relationship like
with social media I think that when I
showed my personality too much or shared
a little bit too much people just had
more access to say things about the real
me so I decided to push back a little
bit and I think definitely when I got
pregnant and started you know having
kids I think that I just have a
different relationship with social media
and I think my priorities are just in a
different place yeah that real life
includes managing a business Empire and
a relationship on the Rocks but at least
she's getting a breath of fresh air
foreign
[Music]